first of all is it true that your
favorite snack is oh I will gummy bears
thank gosh because oh my God it was a
little bit of a test and I heard is it
true Glenn that you would get her Gummy
Bears this is true she doesn't drink
caffeine she just eats gummy bears and
just gets uh sugar highs throughout day
it's so funny cuz I drink nothing but
caffeine Glenn what is your favorite
snack Butterfinger
oh gosh I'm so relieved look at you best
car ride I've ever my God so this is my
minivan it's only minivans and nothing
else and is it true that you drove a
Toyota Previa in 1990 not in 1990 a 1990
Toyota Previa oh understood I was 2
years old and I how old you were really
old I should not be doing this WR well I
was going to say that's a joke in the
movie and I don't get it cuz you guys
seem like a Perfect Chemistry match and
by the way like I did a movie with Hugh
Grant and he was a few years older than
me and I never even bumped on it like
age has nothing to do with who the
person is it's life experience and
chemistry is chemistry so I don't care
how old you both are you're perfect
mat yes I drove a a 1990 Toyota Previa
which was handed down to me from my Mom
they're the my favorite minivan my
ex-boyfriend Eric erinson from the band
hole drove a Toyota Previa in Seattle
and he took the middle seats out it was
only the back bench and that's where
he'd put all his guitars and it was my
favorite car in the entire world same
thing no me and Eric
yeah incredible producing job on this
film by the way honestly you as the
leader of the team here you know the
person that really like developed this
movie no truly like Syne came up the
idea to make much of do about nothing
into a romcom developed the script like
brought me on board brought will on
board and like built this entire really
impressive thing out there's really no
box you don't check Miss Sweeny design
restoration of automobiles best actress
as someone who wanted to produce the
films I was in so that I would have a
hand in having a seat at the table to
make sure I protected especially a
director's Vision like what made did you
think that will was the right person to
direct this film I mean will has
directed some iconic romcoms that Glenn
and I both truly loved and we couldn't
have imagined someone better to bring be
and Ben to life like and what I love too
saying about fighting for a director
this movie was originally set in Italy
and will fought for Australia and and
it's a character in the movie some
places are Superfluous no it was so was
not so much so that is it true you guys
had to wear ankle bracelets to W off
sharks because Australia water is
infested it's like the experiences that
we get to have it's like and no other
job would we get to but sharks well the
funny the funny part is like Sydney
actually handles a live spider in this
movie right she pulls a spider out of my
pants they have a spider Wrangler on set
so they literally have someone that
takes the the spiders got a name and
they're like they're they're soothing
the spider only can work for so many
minutes at a time and then it needs a
break of course but the problem is it
gives you false sense of confidence that
this thing is trained yes and then it
bite Sydney it did yes no yes I'm like
oh cool and he goes yes the spider just
stay there was he like oh no both Fang I
had two marks right on my wrist we have
a red light we have red light
confessions okay you go first uh what's
the worst place to meet someone for a
date oh gosh what would be the worst
place worst place to meet someone on a
date is where you take other dates
that's a good one you want to be special
just don't I I wouldn't say have a
consistent date spot I would say that's
smart that's smart make it unique I'll
tell you where mine worst one is dinner
because more than not you know before
the appetizer you don't want to be there
toally and what's your Red Light
confession craziest thing you've done
and gotone Away
with I don't want to get in trouble my
first car my grandparents gave me uh was
this old 19 like 90 Volvo and it had a
sunroof and my friends and I would go to
moland and carer at night I do crazy
things on malland too it's the best road
the best feeling here's to hot doging it
on M Halland you hot dogging ladies on
[Music]
M